wir sind heute im norden mexikos an der
universidad de sonora und unser thema
heute sind emotionen
dafür haben wir uns ein bisschen hilfe
geholt von den studenten hier die hier
deutsch lernen und wir versuchen euch
jetzt ein paar beispiele zu zeigen um
emotionen auf deutsch zu beschreiben los
geht's
[Musik]
arthur ist traurig denn ivana hat ihn
verlassen
sie ist jetzt mit ab dir zusammen
[Musik]
die rallye ist panisch sie hat
platzangst
[Musik]
der weihnachtsmann hat mich leben
der lehrer hat seiner lieblings
schülerin kuchen mitgebracht die ganze
klasse ist eifersüchtig
die bahn cloud conchita den kuchen
conchita ist wütend
die schüler sind müde
denn sie haben gestern zu lange gefeiert
[Musik]
oskar ist verzweifelt er muss dringend
zur toilette die schüler leben über ihre
iphones autor hat kein iphone
er fühlt sich ausgegrenzt louis iphone
ist kaputt gegangen
arthur ist ein bisschen schadenfroh
ab der ist glücklich er hat 200
drehschuss gefunden
[Musik]
arthur ist heute mutig nirvana ist
überrascht
[Musik]
janisch ist stolz denn er hat gestern
ein gitarrenkonzert gespielt die
studenten freuen sich so sehr dass sie
die ode an die freude singen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe ihn einst francisco ist
neidisch auf albahari das ist eklig
alex zeigt einen zaubertrick carlos ist
beeindruckt
claudia bis ganz schön neugierig
er hat höhenangst
ich hatte
oh ist das peinlich
das war unser video zum thema emotionen
vielen dank an die studierenden und
lehrerinnen und lehrer der universität
der sonora die diese ganzen emotionen
hervorragend schauspielerisch
dargestellt haben
und jetzt seid ihr dran und können
selbst noch ein bisschen üben ihr könnt
neue vokabeln lernen das ganze
interaktiv mit videos probiert das mal
aus in unserer app ceiling hier könnt
ihr direkt zur app gehen und das
ausprobieren wir freuen uns auf euer
feedback vielen dank dass ihr diese
woche der beirat vielen dank dass ihr da
wart und wir sind euch viele grüße aus
dem norden mexikos
[Musik]